valójában áldozatokká válunk vagy pedig
önként vállalva vállaljuk azt hogy ott
maradunk és és ez ez a keresztény út
valójában az önként vállalt szenvedésnek
az útja hogyha akármi is legyen az amit
vállalunk az önként legyen ne az
áldozatai legyünk ennek pontosan
pontosan és én csak azt tudom tanácsolni
azoknak a hallgatóknak
akik akik most nagyon mélyen
elgondolkoztak hogy most mihez kezdjenek
ebben a pillanatba hogy képezzék magukat
először is titokban anélkül hogy
megmondanák ezt nyilván a másik
személynek képezzék magukat nézzenek
utána győződjenek meg róla hogy tényleg
félreértették a helyzetet vagy pedig
vagy pedig jól látják